hello everyone and welcome to the other
match from the semi-finals of the Julius
bear generation cup it is the second
game and it's the one that we are going
to show as I think it is the nicest one
uh for for people to enjoy even though
the match consisted of six games but
we're gonna discuss that a little bit
after we check out the game uh so let's
dive straight into it it's Arjun
erikaisy versus Quang Liam Li uh really
uh a wonderful game so Arkham with the
white pieces opened with E4 we have E5
by elimlet Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and
the bishop the C4 the Italian game is on
the board Bishop to C5 and now C3 Arjun
does not go for the strongest move here
but C3 will suffice Knight to F6 with D3
and D6 now we are in the Joko pianissimo
variation of the um of the main line
castles castles and now we have Bishop
to G5 which is not played that often
more more often here you will see Bishop
B3 Knight bd2h3 but here Bishop to G5
this is the
um well it's a very tricky line and you
have to know a whole lot of theory as it
allows H6 G5 and then you have to decide
you want to play that or do you want to
sacrifice in G5 and then try and win
like this and the black has shown uh
more than once that black can defend
this fairly easily so okay H6 Bishop H4
and now A5 saying you are not getting
that pawn to B4 anytime soon Rook to E1
and now there is a game from last year's
uh fide Grand Prix or rather Video Grand
Swiss between around aksadvani and even
chaparino where uh G5 immediately was
played the game ended in a draw but here
we have Bishop to A7 by Liam and it is
now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game I believe in the
game that we've shown between Magnus and
Vincent also it was a new move already
as of move nine so you know very
interesting stuff uh Knight beat the D2
and now we have Pawn to G5 and now you
have to decide do you want to sacrifice
on G5 or not for example if you do okay
it looks very nice you are preparing to
bring your queen into F3 put pressure on
the Knight but black can defend this
fairly easily with with King to G7 and
then you will just bring the Rook to
help out with the defense and not not
much worry there for example Queen F3
Rook to h8 and it's not easy for white
to create anything here and it's been
played before in similar positions so uh
well it's possible and it's even I
believe the the top move recommended by
the engine uh uh Arjun says that it's
not something worthy of pushing for a
win so Bishop G3 Knight to H7 and now
Pawn to D4 not waiting for uh for some
like moving the king and then Pawn to F5
uh H5 now preparing to trap the bishop
and pawn to H3 making room for the
bishop but now Pawn to G4 busting open
the king side uh sorry H4 first
attacking the bishop Bishop to H2 and
now Pawn to G4 busting open the Queen
the king side captures captures and now
Bishop back to E2 so the Knight can move
and also now help out with the defense
of the D4 Square Queen to F6 and now
Knight the C4 putting more pressure on
the E5 square e captures on D4 and now
while you would expect something like C
captures or Knight captures nope here
Arjun plays Pawn to E5 and this is uh
truly a spectacular idea now it's hard
to say if Arjuna has this prepared at
home or did he find This brilliant
inspiration over the board because it
was Liam Lee who went into a new
position it wasn't Arjun who surprised
Liam Lee but surviving this with black
if you haven't seen this would be
extremely difficult that was just for
fun I will show you the the engine line
that says that black is okay from this
position starts with queen to G7 which
is you know not the first move that
comes to mind as there's so much tension
in the center and now after Knight
captures on H4 opening up an attack here
on the bishop of Bishop back to E6 and
after Bishop D3 now you play D5 you
chase away the Knight Knight D2 captures
captures and not Knight the G5 so this
is if you if you find this over the
board you will be okay with black if not
uh chances are you are gonna lose this
uh well uh terribly so D captures on E5
is what was played by Liam Lee and now
Knight C characters on E5 Bishop capture
F3 Bishop captures and F3 now the rook
and the bishop defend the Knight so it's
not a problem and now again you have to
play Knight to G5 but here the captors
and C3 was played uh obviously expecting
B captures on C3 but here Arjun plays
the Incredible Knight to D7 attacks the
queen attacks the rook and what can you
do here well Quinta F5 is played and
here a big trap is set up but Arjun has
a completely winning position here if
you find the idea that he had and it's
not a not a simple one so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
what Arjun had in mind while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh starting uh to
calculate Knight captures and f8 it's
it's a valiant move but it's not the
move that wins the game the move that
wins the game is Bishop to E4 so really
congratulations to everyone who found
this because you allow queen or Bishop
captures on F2 and that's not uh you
know easy to spot that this is okay I
will just quickly show what happens if
Knight captures an f8 then see captures
and beat you threatens the rook and now
okay you can capture on H7 B captures an
A1 Queen captures and now Queen captures
on H7 you get this position where uh
black is up a few pawns but uh White has
the best repair the black king is uh
kind of open the queen controls this
diagonal so it would be white who would
be pushing for the win here it's not
however as clean after Queen to F5
Bishop to E4 the move Arjun played now
really makes it impossible for for black
to survive this he struts with Queen
captures and F2 with check King the H1
and not Knight to F6 again the the
strongest move but not not much other
than that it's simply not enough here
just Bishop captures on C6 B captors in
Rook to F1 now if the queen moves of
course the Knight hangs for free with
check so C2 again the the only move the
strongest move but now uh Queen to C1 of
course if you if you play some like
Knight captures on F6 check Queen
captures you are still attacking the
queen but your queen is also hanging and
if you play Queen captures and C2 Queen
G6 offers a queen trade and black
survives this so here after Queen to C2
Arjun just played Queen to C1 and now
there is no move uh the ones the queen
moves you just pick up the free Knight
so here umlet tried Queen captures on F1
giving up the queen for for rook and the
in the Knight but it is not enough Queen
captures Knight captures on D7 now Queen
to F5 attacking the Knight attacking the
pawn on C2 and here again you could try
some like rookie to d8 then okay it's uh
you defend the night the the C2 Pawn
will hang but here Liam let tries one
last idea rook fd8 and now if the Knight
is captured he will bring the other Rook
into the game and hopefully land this
Rook on D1 but Arjun calculates
precisely he plays Queen captures on D7
Rook 8 to d8 and now of course Queen to
G4 check first the very important move
as it regards the D1 Square twice now
with the queen and the Rook so Rook D1
is not a problem King f8 and now Bishop
to F4 uh freeing of that H2 Square for
the king you know just uh you know for
safety Bishop to E3 and not just the
bishop captures not worrying about
anything we have Rook the F1 preparing
to set up a mating attack here with
Queen H5 and now just Pawn to H3 trying
something to open up the white king we
have Queen H5 threatening Checkmate and
now age captures on G2 with check King
captures Rook to D2 check but just King
back to H1 and yes you do have the Rook
pair the pawn is nicely placed ready for
promotion on on C2 but the rook and
queen both regard the D1 Square so Rook
D1 is impossible and also Checkmate is
being threatened so King E8 uh trying to
run away with the King if you can hide
the king maybe on B7 and not allow any
further checks you will have some
chances uh but uh you know uh Queen
captures and F7 checking the d8 Queen
the G8 with check King to D7 and now
Rook F7 check uh uh now rookie seven and
just Rook captures on E7 and now of
course you cannot capture here because
Queen G5 check picks up the rook and
also guards the queening square so I
have to root capture as an E7 checking
the D6 was played but now just a nice
Queen to d8 check and he was in this
position on move 41 that uh uh uh Huang
Liam resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here once the
king moves let the king here Queen
captures and D2 guards the queening
square of course there's nothing to have
to play for here uh so after this uh
wonderful uh wonderful move and this
wonderful combination
um uh Arjun took the lead in the match
this was the second game of the match
then game three ended in a draw and then
in game four Arjun only needed a draw
with the white pieces however he
blundered terribly in the Liam won a
very very nice game uh he forced tie
breaks but in the tie breaks Arjun just
won both games very convincingly and
thus rightfully uh you know took his
place uh in the finals of the Julius
bird generation cup where he will face
none other than Magnus Carlsen uh so I
mean it's just a just a spectacular idea
this um uh after this uh sorry
uh got a bit too far there after this
Exchange in the center this E5 move like
I said I don't know if it's prepared at
home or he found it over the board but
regardless maybe it was a you know a
spur of inspiration maybe you know it's
sort of some sort of a brilliant moment
uh but uh finding a defense against the
E5 is not the easy Endive I I don't
think it's possible in a rapid game over
the board so yeah very nicely done by
Arjun for those of you who are maybe
just joining in the event these are the
this is what happened basically in The
Knockout phase first we had the
preliminaries uh where the 16 players
were playing and then the final eight
proceeded Into The Knockout phase uh
where Magnus Carlsen defeated level on
arunan three to one he proceeded to the
semi-finals of instant climber defeated
pragnananda uh also three to one where
he uh faced Magnus Carlson we've already
seen that match in the previous video
Magnus defeated Vincent and proceeded to
the to the finals and uh in the other
part of the bracket Liam defeated the
The Legend Hans Neiman Arjun irriguez he
was better than Christa for you then now
we've seen how Arjun defeated Liam Lin
and in the finals over the next two days
we will see the match Arjun irrigation
versus Magnus Carlsen as Magnus also
praised him very much uh in his
interview he is uh I believe Arjun is
now I believe number 18 or 19 I believe
it's it's it's Arjun and gukish so they
are like number 18 and number 19 in the
world classical
so they they have improved tremendously
over the over the past year and I
believe Magnus is very very happy to
face Arjun um uh in the final so we'll
see what happens next two days will be
uh filled with with great chess uh Arjun
has a great opportunity here uh he's
been playing incredible chess will he be
able to take down one Magnus Carlsen
we'll see uh so uh stay tuned for that
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Stuart Matthews Derek King Brian parking
golden pawn and mcdishokui for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
finals until it finishes so thank you
all I will see you soon and uh have an
excellent rest of your day